the guest of honor at that school's
opening was the First Minister of Wales
Cohen Jones
so we also spoke to him and he had some
pretty interesting things to say about
brexit and the checkers deal but I
started by asking him about the impact
of the starting well it means there's
less money around it means that it's
very difficult for local authorities to
find the money they need very difficult
for us as a Welsh government to find the
money that we need to make sure that we
can keep the health service and
education in the place where we'd want
but we've managed to do it over the past
10 years but there come a time in the
next few years when it'll be very very
difficult to to sustain and what we've
done so far there's been talk of a
Western powerhouse and by the Welsh
secretary do you see much evidence of
that of investment of new job creation
in Wales in this era no not from the UK
government the UK government takes money
away it doesn't invest ok I'm not quite
sure he means by it
if he means should we cooperate with
Bristol and the other side assemble of
course I mean you know you having a
cross-border cooperation even whether
they're international borders you get
that in Ireland for examples there's no
reason why we shouldn't be able to work
together to create prosperity we do the
same in the northeast of Wales the
economy of the northeast of Wales is
closely connected with Chester and
Merseyside it would be daft if we simply
said we're just going to look at the
northeast of Wales purely on the basis
of it being self-contained so yeah of
course we want to to work with others to
get to get the best breakfast of course
it's something that we can't avoid
always in any sort of interview at the
minute and Wales voted to leave a
Bridgend voted to leave the EU how do
you think that is going to impact this
area depends what it looks like the
problem is two years ago people were
asked to vote on a concept not a plan no
one could say to people if you vote to
leave this is exactly what will happen
and now of course we've got this mess
because the hardliners say don't be
afraid of a No Deal and that people like
me who say ok people voted to leave the
EU they didn't vote to leave the single
market or customs in anyone asked
because neither of those things are
requiring membership
people did not say to me on the doorstep
we need to leave the European Medicines
Agency mean don't say that so for me
it's got to be a sensible for Exeter No
Deal barracks it is disastrous for us
because 60% of our exports in Wales go
to the single market
90% of our food and drink products that
are exported go to the single market any
tariff barriers or non-tariff barriers
yeah I can imagine with food delays at
the post the food goes off
Lily fish that's bad for us and that's
not what people we're told two years ago
nobody said one of the possibilities is
in Odile brexit no one nice offer I
didn't say that
they all said there'll be a deal don't
worry there'll be a deal the European
Union will give us a deal quickly the
German car manufacturers will only force
the use and it has no well do you think
then the Labor Party should effectively
support the government on checkers if
you're worried about No Deal scenario
that would be the responsible thing for
labor to do it's very very difficult see
what checkers is going to go I think
check is a still a flavor supports it
then it's a step in the right direction
yeah I'm not I'm not going to say
checkers it's something I don't welcome
I do
to an extent because it takes us it's
not as far as we would want to go I have
to say but it's it's the right directors
far better than a No Deal
but this is not about what happens in
the Labor Party the consoler party is
actually split over braixen it's it's a
nodes if just I can make political
mischief and say isn't it awful what the
Tories are doing but it's no good for
the country you know at the end of the
day this is about more than politics
this is about making sure that people
have a living and a livelihood once we
leave the EU and I don't think at the
moment we're seeing any real leadership
from from conservative politicians go do
a second referendum does that tempt you
I don't think were there yet
I think there might come a time when a
second referendum becomes inevitable
let's say for example there's no deal
agreed in Parliament well how do you
resolve it that an election general
election let's say that the result of
that election that was inconclusive is
the last one well how then do you
resolve it other than by going back to
the same people who took the initial
decision and saying look no you know
what the possibilities are
what's your view now